l' incendie qui a ravagé un immeuble de
six étages ce matin dans le centre de
paris dans le 2ème arrondissement a fait
finalement à mort il s'agit d'un ouvrier
de 21 ans qui n'a pas pu sortir d'une
pièce où il s'était réfugié
d'énormes moyens ont dû être mises en
oeuvre pour maîtriser le feu qui avait
pris dans une cave et qui s'était
rapidement propagé par la cage de
l'ascenseur et les escaliers un mois et
demi après l incendie dramatique du
collège de la rue edouard pailleron à
paris un incendie qui avait fait 20
morts
on a appris hier soir les résultats de
l' enquête administrative
plusieurs anomalies dans la construction
du bâtiment ont été constatés elles
seront évidemment porté au dossier
sans préjuger des suites judiciaires qui
seront données à cette affaire les
poteaux porteurs en acier devait être
protégé par un enduit à base d'amiante
dans la partie non visible à hauteur d
au plafond il ne l'était pas dans le
vide des faux plafonds devait se trouver
un cloisonnement coupe feu il n'y en
avait pas la façade était doublée pour
une isolation thermique par des plaques
de polystyrène expansé c'est un produit
dangereux qui n'aurait pas dû se trouver
là ce sont les trois différences que l'
enquête administrative a décelé entre le
cahier des charges et le bâtiment
définitif mais attention on ne peut pas
affirmer à l'heure actuelle que ces
anomalies de construction ont joué un
rôle dans la propagation du feu c'est au
juge sablayrolles chargé de l'enquêté
judiciaire de le dire en attendant on
peut s'interroger
plusieurs faits dramatiques ces temps
derniers nous ont laissés en désarroi ce
désarroi caire le public n'est plus
habitué au feu dans un appartement
moderne on ne voit plus de feu alors que
nos anciens avaient l'habitude du feu il
le voyait tous les jours dans le poil
est avant dans leur cheminée et puis et
la sagesse élite et ses anciens nous
donner le moyen de nous défendre contre
un incendie alors que nous avions peu de
moyens quand je dis défend mme joly
dudit de prévenir et à prévenir incendie
au moyen âge notamment en prenant soin
de revêtir de plâtre les maisons à pans
de bois et c'était donnons une
ordonnance royale qui le prescrivait
y'en a encore une fois 1762 577 qui doit
être de cornell parce que maintenant on
ne sait plus se préserver si on sait
lutter contre le feu mais il faut dire
que la construction moderne utilise des
matériaux qui contiennent un potentiel
calorifique tels que le moindre incendie
plan d alu logarithmique libère en très
peu de temps un énorme potentiel
calorifique en atteignant des pics de
température et toutes les conséquences
c'est à dire que tout ce qui est tout ce
qui vient de la chimie organique il
commence par distiller l'air et appauvri
à l'oxygène ils se produisent oxyde de
carbone dont la dose létale est très
rapidement atteintes epona des
catastrophes et des pertes humaines bien
pour les feux de demain on n'est pas
tellement des armées parce que on a déjà
de sérieux règlement de prévention mais
il faut se dire que nous aurons à
parfaire de ses règlements et que c'est
là une tâche continue il faudra
évidemment fait en sorte qu' on puisse
intervenir très vite et quand julien
intervenir le donnait d'abord la lèvre
avant oclio feu et tout le monde se
sauver à leur bible il faut qu'on
reprenne ce vieux réflexe
en fait ce qu'il faut c'est ne pas se
contenter des règlements qui existent il
faut ne pas dire ne pas hésiter à
refaire sans cesse et règlements ces
règlements ne sont pas immuables
ils ne sont pas figées il faut qu'ils
soient sans cesse sur le métier la
sécurité a toujours un peu de retard sur
les techniques de pointe et il faut que
ce pas ne se transforme pas en force
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]